nicolas rue d'auch s'est installée en
2011 sur l'exploitation familiale 120
hectares de céréales blé orge et maïs
irrigué entre temps la situation des
céréaliers s'est dégradée économiquement
aujourd'hui les seuls sur l'exploitation
c'est plutôt une exploitation des zones
intermédiaires à une exploitation où on
peut faire des céréales mais où on peut
aussi faire de l'élevage donc il ya une
soixantaine d'années
le choix a été fait de la m que en
céréales et donc on continue c'est pas
toujours facile mais on continue
j'utilise plein d'eau a des doutes id
aide à la décision moi tous les
traitements qui sont réalisés sont
réalisés sur un diagnostic bien précis
que ce soit par satellite ou par
prélèvement au chant si j'avais plus ces
produits phytosanitaires je serai
confronté à de gros soucis qui pourrait
mettre en péril la compétitivité de mon
exploitation
nicolas rudeau fait donc partie de ces
agriculteurs pour lesquels l'utilisation
de phytosanitaires s'intègre à ses
process de culture même s'il fait un
usage qui l'estiment raisonnée du
glyphosate en moyenne pour une
exploitation comme la mienne de 120
hectares entre 100 et 150 litres ce qui
équivaut à entre un petit peu plus d'un
litre à l'hectare bon j'essaye de mettre
des pratiques en place qui nous
permettent de plus de dents n'utiliser
le moins possible en tout cas tout ce
qui peut aller dans le sens de
l'amélioration des cultures
nicolas lemay en place sur ses terres je
crois qu'on n'a pas forcément attendu
que l'interdiction ou la pseudo
interdiction nous tombe sur le nez pour
travailler sur les économies de produits
phyto bon moi personnellement sur mon
exploitation j'essaye de m
en place ce qu'on appelle une rotation
avec des cultures d'automne et de
printemps ce qui me permet d'alterner
les matières actives utilisées et aussi
de casser le cycle des mauvaises herbes
la petite phrase d'emmanuel macron sur
la difficulté à interdire d'ici trois
ans le glyphosate l'a un peu rassuré il
espère que le président a pris
conscience des risques encourus pour
l'activité économique agricole du pays